الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
واذا وقع القول عليهم اخرجنا لهم دابه
من الارض تكلمهم
تكلمهم ان الناس كانوا باياتنا
يوقنون
ويوم نحشر من كل امه فوجا ممن يكذب
باياتنا فهم يوزعون
حتى اذا جاؤوا
قال اكذبتم
باياتي ولم تحيطوا بها علما
ام ماذا كنتم تعملون
ووقع القول عليهم بما ظلموا فهم لا ينطقون
الم يروا انا جعلنا الليل ليسكنوا فيه
والنهار مبصرا
ان في ذلك لايات لقوم يؤمنون
ويوم ينفخ في الصور فافزع من في السماوات
ومن في الارض الا من شاء
الله
وكل اتوه داخرين
وترى الجبال تحسبها جامده وهي تمر مر
السحاب
صنع الله الذي اتقن كل شيء
انه
خبير
بما تفعلون
من جاء بالحسنه فله خير منها وهم من فزع
يومئذ امنون
ومن جاء بالسيئه فكبت وجوههم في النار هل
تجزون الا ما كنتم تعملون
انما امر رت ان اعبد رب هذه البلده الذي
حرمها وله كل شيء
وان اكون من المسلمين
وامرت ان اكون من المسلمين
انما امرت ان اعبد رب هذه البلده الذي
حرمها وله كل شيء وامرت ان اكون ون
المسلمين
وان اتلو القران
فمن اهتدى فانما يهتدي لنفسه ومن ضل ومن
ضل فقل انما انا من المنذرين
وقل الحمد لله سيريكم اياته
فتعرفونها
وما ربك بغافل عما
تعملون
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
طا سين
م
تلك ايات الكتاب المبين
نتلو عليك من نب ء موسى وفرعون بالحق لقوم
يؤمنون
ان فرعون على في الارض وجعل اهلها شيعا
يستضعف طائفه
منهم يستضعف طائفه
منهم يذبح ابناءهم
ويستحيي نساءهم
انه كان من المفسدين
ونريد ان نمن على الذين استطعفوا في الارض
ونجعلهم ائمه
ونجعلهم الوارثين
ونمكن لهم في الارض ونري فرعون وهامان
وجنودهما منهم ما كانوا يحذرون
واوحينا الى ام موسى ان ارضعيه فاذا خفت
عليه فالقيه في اليم ولا تخافي ولا تحزني
انا رادوه
اليك وجاعلوه من المرسلين
فالتقطه ال فرعون ليكون لهم عدوا وحزنا
ان فرعون وهامان وجنودهما
كانوا ظالمين
كانوا
[Arabic recitation]
وقالت قالت امراه فرعون قره عين لي ولك
وقالت امراه فرعون قره عين لي ولك
لا تقتلوه عسى ان ينفعنا او نتخذه ولدا
وهم لا يشعرون
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
شيخ
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
واصبح فؤاد
ام موسى فارغا ان كادت لتبدي به
ان كادت لتبدي به لولا ان ربطنا على قلبها
لتكون من المؤمنين
وقالت لاخته قصيه
فبصرت به عن جنب وهم لا يشعرون
وحرم نا عليه المراضع من قبل فقالت فقالت
هل ادلكم على اهل بيت يكفلونه
لكم وهم له ناصحون
فرجعناه الى امه كي تقر عينها ولا تحزن
وردد فرددناه الى امه كي تقر عينها ولا
تحزن ولتعلم ان وعد الله حق ولكن اكثرهم
لا يعلمون
ولما
بلغ اشده واستوى اتيناه حكما
وعلما
وكذلك نجزي المحسنين
ودخل المدينه على حين غفله
من اهلها
فوجد فيها رجلين يقتتلان
هذا من شيعته وهذا من عدوه فاستغاثه الذي
من شيعته على الذي فاستغاثه
الذي من شيعته على الذي هو عدوه
فاستغاثه
الذي من شيعته على الذي من عدوه فوكزه
موسى فقضى عليه
قال هذا من عمل الشيطان انه
مضل
انه
مضل مبين
عدو
قال رب اني ظلمت نفسي فاغفر لي فغفر له
انه
هو الغفور الرحيم
قال رب بما انعمت علي فلن اكون ظهيرا
للمجرمين
فاصبح في المدينه خائفا
يترقب
فاذا الذي استنصره
بالامس يستصرخه
قال له موسى انك لغوي مبين فلما
اراد ان يبطش بالذي هو عدو لهما
قال يا موسى ان تريد ان تقتلني كما قتلت
نفسا بالامس
ان تريد الا ان تكون جبارا في الارض وما
تريد ان تكون من المصلحين
وجاء
رجل من اقصى المدينه يسعى
قال يا موسى ان الملا ياتمرون بك ليقتلوك
فاخرج خرج اني
لك لمن الناصحين
فخرج منها خائفا
يترقب
قال رب نجني من القوم الظالمين
ولما توجهت القاء مدين قال
قال عسى ربي ان يهديني سواء
السبيل
ولما
ورد ماء مدين وجد عليه
وجد عليه امه من الناس يسكون
وجد عليه امه من الناس يسقون
ووجد من دونهم امراتين تذودان قال ما خطبك
ما قال تعالى نسقي حتى يصدر الرعاء
وابونا شيخ كبير
فسقى لهما ثم تولى الى الظل فقال
فقال رب اني بما ان رب اني لما انزلت الي
من خير فقير
فجاءته
احداهما تمشي على استحياء
قالت
قالت ان ابي يدعوك ليجزيك اجر ما سقيت لنا
فلما جاءه
وقص عليه القصص قال لا تخف نجوت من القوم
الظالمين
قالت قالت احداهما يا ابت استاجره
يا ابت استاجره ان خير من استاجرت القوي
الامين قال اني اريد ان انكحك احدى ابنتي
هاتين على ان تاجرني ثماني حجج
فان اتممت عشرا فمن عندك
وما اريد ان اشق عليك ستجدني ان شاء
الله من الصالحين
قال ذلك بيني وبينك ايما الاجلين قضيت
ايما الاجلين قضيت فلا دون عليه والله على
ما نقول وكيل
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ين
امين
فلما
قضى موسى الاجل وسار باهله انس من جانب
الطور نارا
قال لاهلهم كثوا اني انستنا نارا
لعلي اتيكم منها بخبر او جذوه من النار
لعلكم تصطلون
فلما اتاها نودي من شاطئ الوادي الايمن في
البقعه المباركه من الشجره
من الشجره ان يا موسى اني انا الله رب
العالمين
وان الق عصاك فلما راها تهتز كانها
جان
ولا
ولا مدبر
ولم يعقب يا موسى اقبل ولا تخف انك من
الامنين
اسلك يدك في جيبك تخرج بيضاء
من غير سوء
واضمم اليك جناحك من الرهب فذلك برهان من
ربك فذلك برهان من ربك الى فرعون وملائه
انهم كانوا قوما فاسقين
قال رب اني قتلت منهم نفسا
فاخاف ان يقتلون
واخي هارون هو افصح مني لسانا
فارسله معي ردا يصدقني اني اخاف ان يكذبون
قال سنشد قال سنشد عبدك باخيك ونجعل لكما
سلطانا
فلا يصلون اليكم ما باياتنا
انتم
انتما ومن اتبعكما الغالبون
فلما جاءهم
موسى باياتنا بينات
قال الذين كفروا
قالوا ما هذا الا سحر مفترى
وما سمعنا بهذا في ابائنا من الاولين
وقال موسى ربي اعلم بمن جاء بالهدى من
عنده
ومن
تكون له عاقبه الدار
انه لا يفلح الظالمون
وقال فرعون يا ايها الملا ما علمت لكم من
اله غيري
فاوقد لي يا هامان على الطين فاجعل لي
صرحا فاجعل لي صرحا لعلي اطلع الى اله
موسى
واني لاظنه
من الكاذبين
واستكبر هو وجنوده في الارض بغير الحق
وظنوا انهم الينا لا يرجعون
فاخذناه وجنوده فاخذناه وجنوده فنبذناهم
في اليم
فانظر كيف كان عاقبه الظالمين
وجعلناهم ائمه
يدعون الى النار ويوم القيامه لا ينصرون
واتبعناهم
في هذه الدنيا يا لعنه ويوم القيامه هم
من المقبوحين
ولقد اتينا موسى الكتاب
ولقد اتينا موسى الكتاب من بعد ما من بعد
ما اهلكنا القرون الاولى بصائر للناس
بصائر للناس وهدى ورحمه
وهدى ورحمه لعلهم يتذكرون
وما كنت بجانب الغربي اذ قضينا الى موسى
الامر وما كنت من الشاهدين
ولكن انشانا قرونا فتطاول عليهم العمر
وما كنت ساويا في اهل مدين تتلوا عليهم
اياتنا
ولكننا كنا مرسلين
وما كنت بجانب الطور اذ ناديناه
ولكن رحمه من ربك لتنذر قوما ما اتاهم من
نذير من قبلك لعلهم يتذك رون
ولولا ان تصيبهم مصيبه بما قدمت ايديهم
فيقولوا
فيقولوا ربنا لولا ارسلت الينا رسولا
فنتبع اياتك
فنتبع اياتك ونكون من المؤمنين
فلما جاءهم
الحق من عندنا
قالوا
قالوا لولا اوتي مثل ما اوتي موسى اولم
يكفروا بما اوتي موسى من قبل قالوا سحران
تظاهرا
وقالوا انا بكل كافرون
قل فاتوا بكتاب
هو اهدى منهما
هو اهدى منهما اتبعه ان كنتم صادقين
فان لم يستجيبوا لك فاعلم انما
يتبعون اهواءهم
ومن اضل ممن
يتبع هدى اهواه
ومن اضل ممن اتبع ع هواه بغير هدى من الله
ان الله لا يهدي القوم الظالمين
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
ايه
[Silence]
فتح الله عليك القراءه النهارده كانت
جميله ما شاء اللهط
[Arabic recitation]
الحمد لله السلام ورحمه الله
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
ولقد وصلنا لهم القول لعلهم يتذكرون
الذين اتيناهم الكتاب من قبله هم به
يؤمنون
واذا يتلى عليهم قالوا امنا به انه الحق
من ربنا انا كنا من قبله مسلمين
اولئك يؤتون اجرهم مرتين بما صبروا
ويدرؤون بالحسنه السيئه ومما رزقناهم
ينفقون
واذا سمعوا اللغو اعرضوا عنه وقالوا لنا
اعمالنا ولكم اعمالكم سلام عليكم سلام
عليكم لا نبتغي الجاهلين
انك لا تهدي من احببت ولكن الله يهدي من
يشاء وهو اعلم بالمهتدين
وقالوا ان اتبع الهدى معك نتخطف من ارضنا
اولم نمكن لهم حرما امنا يجبى اليه ثمرات
كل شيء رزقا من لدنا ولكن اكثرهم لا
يعلمون
وكم اهلكنا من قريه بطرت معيشتها
فتلك مساكنهم لم تسكن من بعدهم الا قليلا
وكنا نحن الوارثين
وما كان ربك مهلك القرى حتى يبعث في امها
رسولا يتلوا عليهم اياتنا
وما كنا مهلك القرى الا واهلها ظالمون
وما اوتيتم من شيء فمتاع الحياه الدنيا
وزينتها
وما عند الله خير وابقى افلا تعقلون
افمن وعدناه وعدا حسنا فهو لاقيه كمن
متعناه متاع الحياه الدنيا
ثم هو يوم القيامه من المحضرين
ويوم ويوم يناديهم فيقول اين شركائي
الذين كنتم تزعمون
قال الذين حق عليهم القول ربنا هؤلاء
الذين اغوينا اغويناهم كما غوينا
تبرانا اليك ما كانوا ايانا يعبدون
وقيل ادعوا شركاءكم
فدعوهم فلم يستجيبوا لهم وراوا العذاب
لو انهم كانوا يهتدون
ويوم ينادي ديهم فيقول ماذا اجبتم
المرسلين
فعميت عليهم الانباء
يومئذ فهم لا يتساءلون
فاما من تاب وامن وعمل صالحا فعسى ان يكون
من المفلحين
وربك يخلق ما يشاء
ويختار
ما كان لهم الخيره سبحان الله وتعالى عما
يشركون
وربك يعلم ما تكن صدورهم وما يعلنون
وهو الله لا اله الا هو له الحمد في
الاولى والاخره
وله الحكم واليه ترجعون
قل ارايتم ان جعل الله عليكم الليل سرمدا
الى يوم القيامه من اله غير الله ياتيكم
بضياء
افلا تسمعون
قل ارايتم ان جعل الله عليكم النهار سرمدا
الى يوم القيامه من اله غير الله ياتيكم
بليل تسكنون فيه
افلا تبصرون
ومن رحمته جعل لكم الليل والنهار لتسكنوا
فيه ولتبتغوا من فضله ولعلكم تشكرون
ويوم يناديهم فيقول اين شركائي
الذين كنتم تزعمون
ونزعنا من كل امه شهيدا فقلنا هاتوا برهان
كم فعلموا ان الحق لله وضل عنهم ما كانوا
يفترون
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحم الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ان قارون كان من قوم موسى فبغى عليهم
واتيناه من الكنوز ما ان مفاتحه لتنوء
بالعصبه اولي القوه اذ قال له قومه لا
تفرح ان الله لا يحب الفرحين
وابتغ فيما اتاك الله الدار الاخره ولا
تنسيبك من الدنيا واحسن كما احسن الله
اليك
ولا تبغ الفساد في الارض ان الله لا يحب
المفسدين
قال انما اوتيته على علم عندي اولم يعلم
ان الله قد اهلك من قبله من القرون من هو
اشد منه قوه واكثر جمعا ولا يسال عن
ذنوبهم المجرمون
فخرج على قومه في زينته قال الذين يريدون
الحياه الدنيا يا ليت لنا مثل ما اوتي
قارون انه لذو حظ عظيم عظيم
وقال الذين اوتوا العلم ويلكم ثواب الله
خير لمن امن وعمل صالحا ولا يلقاها الا
الصابرون
فخسفنا به وبداره الارض فما كان له من فئه
ينصرونه من دون الله وما كان من المنتصرين
واصبح ح الذين تمنوا مكانه بالامس يقولون
ويك ان الله يبسط الرزق لمن يشاء من عباده
ويقدر
لولا امن الله علينا لخسف بنا وكانه لا
يفلح الكافرون
تلك الدار الاخره نجعلها للذين لا يريدون
علوا في الارض ولا فسادا والعاقبه للمتقين
من جاء بالحسنه فله خير منها ومن جاء
بالسيئه فلا يجزى الذين عملوا السيئات الا
ما كانوا يعملون
ان الذي فرض عليك القران لرادك
الى معاد
قل ربي اعلم من جاء بالهدى ومن هو في ضلال
مبين
وما كنت ترجو ان يلقى اليك الكتاب الا
رحمه من ربك فلا تكونن ظهيرا للكافرين
فلا تكونن ظهيرا للكافرين
ولا يصدنك عن ايات الله بعد اذ انزلت اليك
وادع الى ربك ولا تكونن
من المشركين
ولا تدع مع الله الها اخر لا اله الا هو
كل شيء هالك الا وجهه له الحكم واليه
ترجعون
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الم
م
احسب الناس ان يتركوا ان يقولوا امنا وهم
لا يفتنون
ولقد فتن ان الذين من قبلهم فليعلمن الله
الذين صدقوا وليعلمن
الكاذبين
ام حسب الذين يعملون السيئات ان يسبقونا
ساء ما يحكمون
من كان يرجو لقاء الله فان اجل الله لا
وهو السميع العليم ومن جاهد فانما يجاهد
لنفسه ان الله لغني عن العالمين
والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات لنكفرن عنهم
سيئاتهم ولنجزينهم
احسن الذي كانوا يعملون
ووصينا الانسان بوالديه حسنى وان جاهداك
لتشرك بي لك به علم فلا تطعهما
الي مرجعكم فانبئكم بما كنتم تعملون
والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات لندخلهم
في الصالحين
ومن الناس من يقول امنا بالله فاذا اوذي
في الله جعل فتنه الناس كعذاب الله
ولئن جاء نصر من ربك ليقولن انا كنا معكم
اوليس الله باعلم بما في صدور العالمين
وليعلمن الله الذين امنوا وليعلمن
المنافقين
وقال الذين كفروا للذين امنوا اتبعوا
سبيلنا ولنحمل خطاياكم
وما هم بحاملين من خطاياهم من شيء انهم
لكاذبون
وليحملن
اثقالهم واثقالا مع اثقالهم وليسالن يوم
القيامه عما كانوا يفترون
ولقد ارسلنا نوحا الى قومه فلبث فيهم الف
سنه الا 50 عاما فاخذهم الطوفان وهم
ظالمون
فانجيناه واصحاب السفينه وجعلناها ايه
للعالمين
وابراهيم اذ قال لقومه اعبدوا الله واتقوه
ذلكم خير لكم ان كنتم تعلمون
انما تعبدون من دون الله اوثانا وتخلقون
افكا ان الذين تعبدون من دون الله لا
يملكون لكم رزقا فابتغوا عند الله الرزق
واعبدوه واشكروا له اليه ترجعون
وان تكذبوا فقد كذب امم من قبلكم وما على
الرسول الا البلاغ المبين
اولم يروا كيف يبدئ الله الخلق ثم يعيده
ان ذلك على الله يسير
قل سيروا في الارض فانظروا كيف بدا الخلق
ثم الله ينشئ النشاه الاخره ان الله على
كل شيء قدير
يعذب من يشاء ويرحم من يشاء واليه تقلبون
وما انتم بمعجزين في الارض ولا في السماء
وما لكم من دون الله
وما لكم من دون الله من ولي ولا نصير
والذين كفروا بايات الله ولقائه
اولئك ياسوا من رحمتي واولئك لهم عذاب
اليم
فما كان جواب قومه الا ان قالوا اقتلوه او
حرقوه فانجاه الله من النار
ان في ذلك لايات لقوم يؤمنون
وقال انما اتخذتم من دون ل اوثانا
موده بينكم في الحياه الدنيا ثم يوم
القيامه يكفر بعضكم ببعض ويلعن بعضكم بعضا
وماواكم النار وما لكم من ناصرين
فامن له لوط
وقال اني مهاجر الى ربي انه هو العزيز
الحكيم
ووهبنا له اسحاق ويعقوب وجعلنا في ذرنيته
النبوه والكتاب
واتيناه اجره في الدنيا وانه في الاخره
لمن الصالحين
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
ولوطا اذ قال لقومه انكم لتاتون الفاحشه
ما سبقكم بها من احد من العالمين
اانكم لتاتون الرجال وتقطعون السبيل
وتاتون في ناديكم المنكر
فما كان جواب قومه الا ان قالوا ائتنا
بعذاب الله ان كنت من الصادقين
قال رب انصرني على القوم المفسدين
ولما جاءت
رسلنا ابراهيم بن بشرى قالوا انا مهلكوا
اهل القريه ان اهلها كانوا ظالمين
قال ان فيها لوطا قالوا نحن اعلم بمن فيها
لننجينه
واهله الا امراته كانت من الغابرين
ولما ان جاءت رسلنا لوطا سيء بهم وضاق بهم
ذرعا وقالوا لا تخف ولا تحزن انا منجوك
واهلك الا امراتك كانت من الغابرين
انا منزلون على اهل هذه القريه رجزا من
السماء بما كانوا يفسقون
ولقد تركنا منها ايه بينه لقوم
يعقلون
والى مدين اخاهم شعيبا فقال يا قوم اعبدوا
الله وارجوا اليوم الاخر ولا تعثوا في
الارض مفسدين
فكذبوه فاخذتهم الرجفه فاصبحوا في دارهم
جاثمين
وعادا وثمود وقد تبين لكم من مساكنهم
وزين لهم الشيطان اعمالهم فصدهم عن السبيل
وكانوا مستبصرين
وقارون وفرعون وهامان ولقد جاءهم موسى
بالبينات فاستكبروا
فاستكبروا في الارض وما كانوا سابقين
فكلا اخذنا بذنبه فمنهم من ارسلنا عليه
حاصبا ومنهم من اخذته الصيحه ومنهم من
خسفنا به الارض ومنهم من خسفنا به الارض
ومنهم من اغرقنا
وما كان الله ليظلمهم ولكن كانوا انفسهم
يظلمون
مثل الذين اتخذوا من دون الله اولياء
كمثل عنك كبوت اتخذت بيتا وان اوهن البيوت
لبيت العنكبوت لو كانوا يعلمون
ان الله يعلم ما يدعون من دونه من شيء وهو
العزيز الحكيم
وتلك الامثال نضربها للناس
وما يعقلها الا العالمون
خلق الله السماوات والارض بالحق ان في ذلك
لايه للمؤمنين
اتل ما اوحي اليك من الكتاب واقم الصلاه
ان الصلاه تنهى عن الفحشاء
والمنكر
ولذكر الله اكبر والله يعلم ما تصنعون
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراطا الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى والذي
قدر فهدى
والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله ثاء
احوى
سنقرئك فلا تنسى الا ما شاء الله
انه
يعلم الجهر وما يخفى ونيسرك لليسرى فذكر
ان نفعت الذكرى
سيذكر من يخشى ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى
النار كبرى
ثم لا يموت فيها ولا يحيا
قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه فصلى
بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا والاخره خير
وابقى
ان
هذا لفي الصحف الاولى
صحف ابراه ابراهيم
وموسى
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
قل يا ايها الكافرون لا اعبد ما تعبدون
ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد
ولا انا عابد ما عبدتم ولا انتم عابدون ما
اعبد
لكم دينكم ولي دين
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد
ولم يكن له كفوا احد
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
ربنا ولك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا مباركا
فيه كما تحب وترضى اللهم تم نورك فهديت
فلك الحمد عظم حلمك فعفوت فلك الحمد بسطت
يدك فاعطيت فلك الحمد
فلك الحمد يا ربنا كما تحب وترضى اللهم صل
على سيدنا محمد في الاولين وصل على سيدنا
محمد في الاخرين
وصل على سيدنا محمد في كل وقت وحين اللهم
صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد حتى ترث الارض ومن
عليها وانت خير الوارثين
اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف عنا اللهم
انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف عنا اللهم انك عفو
تحب العفو فاعف عنا
اللهم لا تدع لنا في مقامنا هذا ذنبا الا
غفرته ولا مريضا الا شفيته ولا مبتلا الا
عافيته
ولا ضالا
الا هديته ولا حائرا الا دللته
ولا ميتا من اموات المسلمين الا برحمتك
رحمته ولا ولا ولدا الا اصلحته
ولا عاص الا هديته
تب علينا برحمتك انك انت التواب الرحيم
اللهم اصلح لنا ديننا الذي هو عصمه امرنا
واصلح لنا دنيانا التي فيها معاشنا
واصلح لنا اخرتنا التي اليها معادنا واجعل
اللهم الحياه الدنيا زياده لنا في كل خير
والموت راحه لنا من كل شر
اللهم واجرنا من خزي الدنيا وعذاب الاخره
اللهم ارحم ضعفنا واجبر كسرنا وسدد
السنتنا
وثبت حجتنا
واقض عنا ديننا
واسلل واسلل سخيمه قلوبنا
واهد قلوبنا
وسدد السنتنا
اللهم تقبل منا انك انت اللهم تقبل منا
صيامنا
وصلاتنا
وزكاتنا
ودعائنا وقيامنا
برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم كن
للمستضعفين من المسلمين في كل مكان
اللهم ادخلهم في ضمانك اللهم اجعلهم في
امانك اللهم ابن عليهم سور سور رعايتك
اللهم ادخلهم في حراستك وادفع عنهم ودافع
يا رب العالمين اللهم اجز والدينا عنا خير
الجزاء اللهم اجز والدينا عنا خير الجزاء
اللهم اجز والدينا عنا خير الجزاء
ومتعهم ومتعهم باعمالهم
واعمالهم
واجعل واجعل قواتهم يا رب العالمين واحفظ
لهم قواتهم ابدا ما ابقيتهم برحمتك يا
ارحم الراحمين اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على
سيدنا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
والتابعين
وارحمنا معهم برحمتك اجمعين سبحان ربك رب
العزه عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
سبحان الم
سبحان